JoJo siwa is once again calling out
Candace Cameron Beret yeah the queer
Superstar made headlines earlier this
year with a Tick-Tock Trend that claimed
Candace was the rudest celebrity she's
ever met the two cents squashed the beef
but now she's calling out the actress
for excluding lgbtq plus stories in film
JoJo posted a screen grab of a recent
headline featuring Candace captioning it
honestly I can't believe after
everything that went down just a few
months ago that she would not only
create a movie with intention of
excluding lgbtqia plus but then also
talk about it in the press this is rude
and hurtful to a whole community of
people now Candace's longtime TV sister
Jody Sweetin commented you know I love
you I had to point that out Stephanie
was always my favorite now for some
background JoJo's Instagram post is
because of a recent interview Candace
did with the Wall Street Journal Candace
who is Chief creative officer of Great
American family network was asked if the
network would potentially include lgbtq
plus couples as leads in Holiday films
to which she responded I think that
great American family will keep
traditional marriage at the core
Bill Abbott the chief executive of Great
American Media added it's certainly the
year 2022 so we're aware of the trends
Trends well One Tree Hill star and
Hallmark star Hillary Burton tweeted now
they're just openly admitting their
bigotry I called this out years ago when
Abbott was at Hallmark glad they dumped
him being lgbtq isn't a trend that guy
and his Network are disgusting YouTube
candy there is nothing untraditional
about same-sex couples
she's not lying she followed that sweet
up with another adding bigot I don't
remember Jesus liking Hypocrites like
candy but sure make your money honey you
ride that prejudice wave all the way to
the bank Hillary was not holding back
and I love it following the backlash
Candace's daughter Natasha defended her
mom on social media posting a picture of
the family saying in part this is an
absolutely vile space for negativity and
I applaud you every time for how you
handle yourself with the utmost Grace
[Music]
hey thanks for watching ET Canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos